In August of 2016, Justin McAroy and I created the next Great Leap Forward in podcasting. A synchronous podcasting. Look it up. It's actually on the Roman Mars Wikipedia page. It all started on my brother and my brother in me episode number 316. Roman Mars says that if there's a revolving door and you use the one next to it that isn't revolving, then you're a monster. Because they're so efficient and great. Can I ask you a question, Justin? I've been meaning to ask you this for a while.
在2016年8月，贾斯汀·麦卡罗伊和我创造了播客界的下一个“大跃进”。一个同步播客。查查看。它实际上在罗曼·马尔斯维基百科页面上。这一切都始于我和我兄弟的播客第316集。罗曼·马尔斯说，如果有旋转门，而你使用了旁边不转的那扇，那你就是个怪物。因为它们效率高又棒。我能问你一个问题吗，贾斯汀？我一直想问你这个。
Uh huh. Why don't you just go do a podcast of Roman Mars? If you would have me, I would love to get over there. I have a lot of good ideas for like, not like this show, but like this show like smart stuff. You know what I mean? Like real thinkers, not like, I can't just, not like smart stuff, you know what I mean? Like real thinkers, not like, I can't just,
嗯哼。你为什么不直接去给罗曼·马尔斯做一个播客呢？如果你愿意，我很乐意去那边。我有很多好主意，不是像这个节目，而是像这个节目那样有深度、讲聪明内容的。你知道我的意思吗？就像真正的思想家，不是像，我不只是，不是像聪明的东西，你知道我的意思吗？就像真正的思想家，不是像，我不只是，
not like this show, but like smart, like, airy-dite podcasting, that's, I feel like my true calling and where I really feel like my lights under a bush was kind of. Justin, do you want to do like a weird backdoor pilot for smart stuff with Justin and Robin right now and just like give us a topic you might discuss on smart stuff?
不是像这个节目，而是像聪明的那种，博学的播客，那是，我觉得那是我的真正召唤，也是我真正觉得自己怀才不遇的地方。贾斯汀，你想现在就为贾斯汀和罗曼的聪明内容做一个奇怪的后门试播集，然后给我们一个你可能会在聪明内容里讨论的话题吗？
Yeah, like I's a one. I'll give you an example and this would be like co-hosts by me and Roman, okay? So I'll kind of leave blanks for you. All to his part. No, I can do Roman. No, I'm just gonna leave blanks for his parts, okay? You don't even wanna hear my Roman?
对，就像这样一个。我给你举个例子，这个将由我和罗曼共同主持，好吗？所以我把他的部分留白。全部留给他的部分。不，我可以模仿罗曼。不，我只是留白他的部分，好吗？你甚至都不想听听我的罗曼吗？
No, you can try later, but I'm just gonna leave blanks for like a reason. Hey guys, it's me, Roman Mars, I'm gonna steal your brother. Got him. That's kind of a nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, guys, it's me, Roman Mars. I'm gonna steal your brother. Got him. Okay. Let's call A.D. You just have a great revive. Nice.
不，你稍后再试，但我留白是有原因的。大家好，我是罗曼·马尔斯，我要偷走你的兄弟。抓到了。这挺不错的，挺好的……大家好，我是罗曼·马尔斯。我要偷走你的兄弟。抓到了。好吧。我们打给A.D.你真是活力满满。太棒了。
So it'll go something like, remember it's like an aerodite kind of smart podcast that yeah, like a podcast where you know the host knows the word aerodite. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that got things. So here's kind of what it would go like. Okay, please. Okay. Please. Hello everybody, welcome to Smart Stuff.
所以大概会是这样，记住它是一个博学的、聪明的播客，对，就像一个你知道主持人懂“博学”这个词的播客。对，对，对，就是那种。所以大致会是这样的情景。好的，请吧。好的。请。大家好，欢迎来到聪明内容。
I am your host Justin McRoy. I'm joined as always, day by Roman Mars. Hey Justin. Roman, what smart thing are we discussing today? Well for episode two of The Smart Stuff Podcast, I'd like to talk about one of my favorite things in population genetics, the founder effect. Mmm! The founder effect is when there's a loss of genetic variation in a new population because it was started by a small number of founders from a larger population.
我是你们的主持人贾斯汀·麦卡罗伊。今天一如既往地有罗曼·马尔斯加入。嘿，贾斯汀。罗曼，我们今天讨论什么聪明的话题？好的，对于《聪明内容播客》第二集，我想聊聊我最喜欢的群体遗传学概念之一：始祖效应。嗯！始祖效应是指新种群由于是由较大种群中的少数始祖创立的，导致其基因变异丧失。
Now, did it? Think of it like this. According to the 2010 US census, the United States is 72.4% white, 16.3% Hispanic or Latino, 12.6% black, and 4.8% Asian. That's the average across all of America. But imagine that one city in the US wanted to start a colony on Mars. Speak on that. That city may not have those proportions or that degree of genetic variation.
那么，是吗？可以这样想。根据2010年美国人口普查，美国有72.4%的白人，16.3%的西班牙裔或拉丁裔，12.6%的黑人，以及4.8%的亚裔。这是全美平均水平。但想象一下，美国的一个城市想在火星上建立一个殖民地。谈谈这个。那个城市可能没有这些比例或那种程度的基因变异。
So for example, the widest city in the US is Scottsdale, Arizona. It's about 90% white. If Scottsdaleans broke off to form their own Martian colony the US is Scottsdale, Arizona. It's about 90% white. If Scottsdaleans broke off the form their own Martian colony, even though Scottsdale is a population within the United States, that colony would have much less genetic diversity than the US population as a whole. Usually, founding populations are much smaller than entire cities. Sure. So imagine there was only two individuals that started a new population.
所以例如，美国白人最多的城市是亚利桑那州斯科茨代尔。大约90%是白人。如果斯科茨代尔人分出来建立他们自己的火星殖民地，美国是亚利桑那州斯科茨代尔。大约90%是白人。如果斯科茨代尔人分出来建立他们自己的火星殖民地，尽管斯科茨代尔是美国境内的一个人口群体，但该殖民地的基因多样性将远低于整个美国人口。通常，创始人口比整个城市要小得多。当然。所以想象一下，只有两个个体创造了一个新的种群。
And then the genes those two individuals carried would be the only genetic variation in the entire gene pool. Uh-huh. Subsequent generations may introduce some random mutations, but otherwise that's it. That's all you're working with. Huh. When it comes to plants and animals and bacteria and isolated founding population with low genetic diversity that by chance had different genetic makeup than the population it came from could lead that new population to becoming a whole new species given enough time.
然后这两个个体携带的基因将成为整个基因库中唯一的基因变异。嗯哼。后代可能会引入一些随机突变，但除此之外就是这样了。这就是你所拥有的全部。哈。当谈到植物、动物和细菌时，具有低基因多样性的孤立始祖种群，如果偶然拥有与其来源种群不同的基因构成，在有足够时间的情况下，可能会导致这个新种群成为一个全新的物种。
But wait, what in that? Now, if the small number of founders of a population have a genetic mutation and the new population remains somewhat isolated, that mutation will be much more common even as the population grows over time. Oh, I see. So, in the 18th century, about 200 families founded the Amish population of Pennsylvania. And at least one of those families
但等等，那又怎样？现在，如果一个种群的少数创始者带有基因突变，并且新种群保持某种程度的隔离，即使种群随着时间推移而增长，这种突变也会变得更加常见。哦，我明白了。所以，在18世纪，大约200个家庭创立了宾夕法尼亚州的阿米什人种群。而这些家庭中至少有一个
had a mutation called polydactyl. What? And even today, the Pennsylvania Amish have much higher rates of polydactyl than the US population as a whole. And that's why, even though it's still quite rare, an Amish person is much more likely to have 11 fingers. It doesn't usually look like a fully formed finger, it's often just a little nub.
带有一种叫做多指症的突变。什么？即使在今天，宾夕法尼亚州的阿米什人多指症的发病率也远高于全美人口。这就是为什么，尽管它仍然相当罕见，阿米什人更有可能拥有11根手指。它通常看起来不像完全形成的手指，通常只是一个小肉瘤。
Well folks, that's all we have time for. This kind of groundbreaking work made by Pioneers in the world, on casting, is only possible because of listener support. Right now, if you go to radiotopia.fm, you'll find a big button that says, pine years in the world of podcasting is only possible because of listener support. Right now if you go to radiotopia.fm you'll find a big button that says, Roman Mars' beautiful nerd brigade. Did you click it? You'll be donating $10. And you'll get an invitation to the online version of my office hours where I will impart onto you in a bunch of other beautiful nerds, all the things I've learned about podcasting
好吧，各位，我们的时间到了。这种由播客世界先驱们所做的开创性工作，只有在听众的支持下才有可能实现。现在，如果你访问 radiotopia.fm，你会发现一个大按钮，上面写着，播客世界的先驱们只有在听众支持下才有可能实现。现在如果你访问 radiotopia.fm，你会发现一个大按钮，上面写着：罗曼·马尔斯的漂亮书呆子旅。你点击了吗？你将捐赠10美元。你将获得我办公时间在线版本的邀请，在那里我将向你和其他许多漂亮的书呆子传授我在过去十多年里学到的关于播客的所有知识
in the last 10 plus years. Clearly, as evidenced by smart stuff, I have a lot of knowledge about podcasting to impart onto you. About 8 of 10,000 listeners to radiotopia donate. That means very likely, you are one of the 9,992 who do not. But you can change that. Go to radiotopia.fm, click the Roman Mars Beautiful Nerv Brigade button and a big group of us will hang out talk about podcasting It's gonna be awesome. We need 35,000 people to be backers to this drive to hit our goal Let's reach that goal together. We made it really really easy. Ten bucks. That's it. You're in the brigade And when you're done send me a note about it on Twitter at Roman Mars, and I will thank you personally. That's radiotopia.fm
很显然，正如《聪明内容》所证明的那样，我有很多关于播客的知识要传授给你们。radiotopia的10,000名听众中大约有8人捐款。这意味着很有可能，你是没有捐款的9,992人之一。但你可以改变这一点。访问 radiotopia.fm，点击“罗曼·马尔斯漂亮书呆子旅”按钮，我们的一大群人将聚在一起讨论播客，这将会很棒。我们需要35,000人成为本次众筹的支持者来达到我们的目标。让我们一起实现这个目标。我们把它变得非常非常简单。十块钱。就这样。你加入这个旅了。当你完成后，在推特上@Roman Mars给我发个便条，我会亲自感谢你。这就是 radiotopia.fm
Thanks What a fascinating tale Thank you and I will thank you personally. That's radiotopia.fm. Thanks. What a fascinating tale. Thank you. Radio Tepia. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。多么迷人的故事。谢谢你，我会亲自感谢你的。这就是 radiotopia.fm。谢谢。多么迷人的故事。谢谢你。来自PRX的Radio Tepia。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子以留下评论。